(audience cheering)
(upbeat rock music)
♪ All last summer, in
case you don't recall ♪
♪ I was yours and you were mine ♪
♪ Forget it all ♪
♪ Is there a line that I could write ♪
♪ That's sad enough to make you cry ♪
♪ And all those lines you
wrote to me were lies ♪
♪ Months roll past the
love that you struck dead ♪
♪ Did you love me only in my head ♪
♪ There were things you
said and did to me ♪
♪ They seem to come so easily ♪
♪ The love I thought I'd won ♪
♪ You give for free ♪
♪ Whispers at the bus stop ♪
♪ Well, I've heard about
nights out in the school yard ♪
♪ I found out about you ♪
♪ Oh, whispers at the bus stop ♪
♪ Well, I've heard about
nights out in the school yard ♪
♪ I found out about you ♪
(audience cheering and applauding)